el número de posibles valores para teta
con 0 menor que teta menor que pi para
los cuales el sistema de ecuaciones
gemma z por el coseno de tres teta es
igual a equis porque por z por el seno
de tres teta y simultáneamente x por
seno de tres teta es igualados por el
coseno de tres z entre y más dos por el
seno de tres teta entre z y
simultáneamente x porque por z por el
seno de tres teta es igual a yemas 12
está por el coste no de 3 z más que por
el seno de tres tetas tiene una solución
x 0 10 000 con 10 0% a 0 distinto de
cero
primero que nada observen que esta
restricción el hecho de que de cero por
z cero tenga que ser distinto de cero lo
único que quiere decir es que de cero
iceta cero no pueden ser cero así que
bueno para empezar mi mente se da cuenta
de que todas las expresiones
trigonométricas involucradas tienen
argumento 3 theta así que podría ser la
sustitución para simplificarle la vida
podría sustituir
igual a tres tetas pero tengo que tener
cuidado porque también tengo esta
condición que cero es menor estricto que
teta menor estricto que pi así que si
eres menor estricto que te da menor
estricto que pin entonces cero tiene que
ser menor estricto que un
y menor estricto y tiene que ser menor
estricto que tres por pi
con eso en mente vamos a cambiar todas
las tres tetas por bus
esto se convierte en una u esto también
se convierte en un esto se convierte en
un esto también se convierte en un esto
uno
esto abre su y también esto
bien ahora lo que quiero hacer es tratar
de igualar estas ecuaciones entonces si
se dan cuenta en todas aparece este
factor de seno de 3 o de alguno de los
dos lados en este caso está del lado
izquierdo y acá del derecho así que bien
pues en esta ecuación si la multiplicó
por si la multiplicó por 10 por zeta
si multiplico toda esta ecuación o ambos
miembros de esta ecuación por ye por
zeta
entonces obtendría x porque por z por el
seno de uke sería lo mismo que tengo acá
arriba y lo mismo que tengo acá abajo
así que también voy a multiplicar de
este lado por por z y también tiene la
consecuencia alegre de que va a cancelar
los denominadores de este lado de la
ecuación del lado derecho así que bien
déjenme reescribir todo esto vamos a
empezar con este azul primero que nada
la primera ecuación voy a pasar x x 10 x
zeta por el seno de d
y lo voy a pasar del lado derecho y
mover esto del lado izquierdo así que mi
primera ecuación lee
x porque por z
por el seno de 1
es igual a voy a distribuir el coseno
así que sería por el coseno de un maceta
por el coseno de mi segunda ecuación
diría
x porque por z por el seno de u
es igual a dos veces que se nos entregue
porque por z las jie se cancelan y me
queda dos veces zeta jose no de v
más
en este caso dos veces seno de eeuu en
13 está por tiempo z se cancelen las
setas y me queda dos veces
seno de un
y la tercera ecuación es así la voy a
dejar bueno voy a expandir esto pero el
lado izquierdo dice
x por 10 por z por el seno de eeuu
es igual
y por el coche no de un
+ 2 zeta
+ 12 está por el coche no dv
más
y por el seno de un muy bien ya que
tengo las ecuaciones escritas de este
modo noten que todos los lados derechos
son iguales entre sí porque todos son
iguales a x porque por z por el seno de
eeuu así que vamos a tratar de cancelar
algunas cosas y vamos a igualar este
lado derecho con este lado derecho los
dos son iguales a x porque por z por el
seno digo así que dos veces z por coseno
de uno más dos veces por el seno de uno
va a ser igual
va a ser igual a por el coche no de uno
más dos veces z por el coseno de un más
que por el seno de uno
entonces bien noten noten que este
término 12 tacos se nos aparece de los
dos lados así que no puedo cancelar
este término cancela a este término y
ahora puedo restar de ambos lados y por
el seno de uno y si hago eso lo que
obtendría sería 210 seno de un -19
obtendría simplemente de seno de eeuu
tiene que ser igual
se cancela acá y sólo me queda seco seno
de un eco seno de eeuu
de este modo tengo una primera
restricción porque los coeficientes de y
que son por un lado seno de v y coseno
de eeuu tienen que ser iguales porque
esto es en cierto modo un polinomio así
que mi primera restricción me diría que
el seno de uno lo hago aquí con amarillo
me diría que el seno de eeuu tiene que
ser igual a el coseno de iu pero en qué
momentos pase esto vamos a tratar de
graficar esto
déjenme pongo mi círculo unitario
este mensajes
y mi círculo unitario se ve algo así
algo así entonces bien para qué valores
coincide el seno con el coseno pues sí
empiezo a recorrer el círculo unitario
en esta dirección
noto que primero tengo un valor aquí que
sería 45 grados o pi cuartos en el que
el seno es igual al coseno continuó
recorriendo el círculo unitario podría
pensar que este punto funciona pero hay
que tener cuidado porque aquí el coche
no es negativo y el pse no es positivo
así que este punto no funciona continúo
continuo continuó hasta que llegó aquí
llegó aquí a cinco cuartos y en cinco pi
cuartos el seno es negativo el coseno
también es negativo y son iguales de
hecho estos dos puntos son
diametralmente opuestos ok continuó
continuó continuó de nuevo este punto no
funciona continuó aquí ya recorrido dos
p ok y ha recorrido dos pi ha hecho una
vuelta completa pero uno tiene que ser
menor que tres pi así que todavía puedo
continuar un cacho más si continúa de
nuevo regreso a este punto y continúo
continuó continuó ya no encuentro ningún
otro
sólo puede llegar hasta este punto de
acá porque solo puedo recorrer tres pi
entonces entonces cuántos valores tuve
pues tuve 12 y luego repetí este 3
lo que hice fue di una vuelta completa
hasta ahí llevo 2 p y luego doy otro
cachito para 3 pi ahora sólo vamos a
checar que no se nos haya escapado
alguna otra restricción bien pues de
osella ya use la segunda y la tercera
ecuación para obtener esta restricción
así que ahora voy a usar la primera y la
tercera y entonces si igualó los
miembros derechos entonces que por el
coseno de v más z por el coseno de v
z por el coseno de v tiene que ser igual
y por el coseno dv
más dos veces z por el coche no de eeuu
más que por el seno de un
bien entonces ahora qué puedo hacer
pues para empezar puedo cancelar en este
caso llegó seno de v está en ambos
miembros de la ecuación así que lo puedo
cancelar dios y adiós y ahora puedo
restarse taco seno de uno de ambos lados
de la ecuación y obtener que 0 va a ser
igual a dos veces z por el coseno de uno
menos z coseno dv sería simplemente z
por el coseno dv
más que por el seno de eeuu
es igual a 0 pero si se fijan en la
segunda ecuación tengo que dos veces
todo esto tiene que ser igual a x por d
por z seno de uno así que déjenme
multiplicar todo esto por dos si
multiplico dos por cero a cero
y esto tiene que ser igual a 2 por z
coseno dv
+ 2 x de seno
dv
y esto a su vez por la segunda ecuación
tiene que ser igual a equis porque por z
por el seno de v entonces para que esto
se valga para que esto se valga como
ni-ni z pueden ser 0 lo que tiene que
pasar es que x va a tener que ser igual
a 0 pero eso no es ninguna restricción
porque el problema no dice nada acerca
de los valores que puede tomar x así que
es perfectamente válido que x sea 0 y en
este caso ya usamos las tres ecuaciones
ya nos dimos cuenta que de la segunda y
la tercera el seno de eeuu tiene que ser
igual al coseno de eeuu y a partir de la
primera la segunda y en perdón la
primera y la tercera y después por la
segunda nos damos cuenta que esa es la
única restricción que tenemos entonces
ahora nosotros sabemos que el seno de v
es igual al coste no de exactamente en
tres lugares entre cero y tres y uno de
ellos sería pi cuartos
y cuartos el otro sería justo acá que
sería pi cuartos más o sea cinco pi
cuartos
cinco cuartos y ahora cinco pi cuartos
más que sería nueve y cuartos
que esencialmente es el mismo ángulo que
y cuartos pero noten que esto es para un
y lo queríamos para theta así que al
dividir estos valores entre 3 obtenemos
los valores de teta que satisfacerían
este sistema y entonces hay tres
soluciones al sistema de ecuaciones